foreign
approaching
[Music]
you still don't remember a thing
I don't remember any of it
I only remember
The Interpreter
[Music]
why he wants this job I need the money
don't disappoint turn out to be a pain
in the ass no not me sir
money isn't the reason he wants his job
and Taliban killed his son
stop the vehicle starting we don't want
to go down this road you're out of your
bounds Ahmed you're here to translate
actually I'm here to interpret
Howie's approaching
well I want
back down for three weeks this family
believed you were dead we are the man
your life it wasn't enough for him to
carry me across those mountains
no he's hiding in a hole somewhere I
should be in that hole
everything all right John no
everything's not all right there is a
hook in me Ahmed and his family are in
trouble we can't intervene
I am actually been about myself
listen You're Gonna Be Alone
here's what you got
if you can give me the location if I can
get them out of the country it's too
dangerous
you become very popular with the Taliban
I miss you love you Daddy
you think if I could be free of this
debt I wouldn't be
you think I have a choice
there is no choice no I Won't
Back Down